good evening ladies and gentlemen um for
many of us the fourth night out this
week on
on council business but
welcome to this meeting of the executive
i will now read out the emergency
evacuation announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the entrance doors to the
hall continue straight on and exit the
building via the double doors on the
right to the car park which is the
assembly point
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please don't do
not return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded please switch off mobile
phones or turn them to silent please
members there are four microphones on
the tables for use during the meeting
when i invite you to speak please wait
until there is a microphone in front of
you before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing loop and for the
audio recording
please where possible assist in passing
microphones to each other and use the
hand gel and the antibacterial wipes on
the tables if you do touch the
microphones
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands for and
against recommendations i will then ask
for any abstentions
we move to agenda item number one which
is apologies for absence
and there are none
item two
non-members attending
councillor ian foster
looking on his lonesome over there but
uh good evening councillor foster
agenda item 3
minutes of the meeting held on the 22nd
of july 21
members are the minutes agreed
thank you
item number four to receive declarations
of interest are there any declarations
of interest members from the agenda
items
that's no from
everyone
item five on the agenda is questions on
notice from councillors and there are
none
which takes us to item number six
matters referred to the executive
reports from other committees again
there are none
agenda item 7
council projects program
management office
and the chief executive officer rockford
district council and brentwood borough
council jonathan stevenson will present
the report jonathan
[Music]
thank you chair
members you have in front of your report
an update on the council's project and
project program management it highlights
three in particular projects the connect
program
um the asset delivery program and the
beagle project
with regards to connect program you will
see in front of you tonight
an investor save project any um later in
the agenda so hopefully that will be
itself a self-explanatory
further investor say projects will be
coming forward later in the autumn as
part of the connect program
the asset development delivery program
in here is that there's an update um
with regard to the programme and again
based on the timeline agreed by
executive there will be a a decision
making paper coming in the autumn as
well um through to the executive or
council i think it's council actually
sorry um thank you um with regard to the
beagle project obviously we all know the
restrictions in 2021 so we're looking at
the the event to be
recasted and planned for summer 2022
full brief and further details report
back to next meeting executive
i'm happy to take any questions or other
officers around the table as well or
portfolio holders
thank you chair
thank you any uh questions from that
report
council fd
oh
um
yes we have been in touch with
rady town council clerk and we're
waiting for us uh meeting with them
so we're gonna put part of the money
hopefully into
into raili to give a big bang on the
trinity fair the ones coming up next
year in conjunction with the queen's
jubilee i think you're doing
and also looking at setting up something
for rochford
um
actually in the middle of oxford as well
so this should be quite
exciting hopefully
thank you councillor fd are there any
other
points or questions
to ask of the report
i see no hand so on that basis we'll
turn to recommendation one set out at
paragraph 1.1
to note
updates on the council's three projects
the connect program and the asset
delivery program
both gold projects and the beagle event
project a silver project is that noted
members
thank you members we moved to agenda
item number eight which is the quarter
one
2021 22 financial year management report
and i will ask councillor simon smith
portfolio holder to present the report
ably i'm sure assisted by
the section 151 officer naomi lucas
councillor smith thank you chairman um
i've already given
members of the executive an informal
briefing on this but for the
purposes of the formality of this
meeting i'll just run through
a few bullet points and
urge you to support the recommendations
printed on
0.2 on the on the report so this is the
quarter one financial monitoring report
purposes are reported to set out
forecast revenue and capital budget
positions at quarter one
the latest revenue budget is eleven
million ninety eight thousand pounds
changes to the original budget are due
to drawdowns from reserves which are
detailed in appendix one
the forecast outrun at quarter one is
eleven million one hundred and sixty
four thousand pounds which gives a small
projected overspend of sixty six
thousand pounds after applying the
council's
general grant allocation but before
any additional funding from the
government income compensation scheme
the variances across individual
portfolio budgets are set out in more
detail in the body of the report and
appendix ii
the council continues to feel the impact
of kovid 19 on its budgets particularly
on car parking which is currently
forecast to be 0.5 of a million below
budget
we report regularly on our expected
financial pressures relating to pandemic
relating to the pandemic to government
central government
the council's coveted 19 grant to cover
general pandemic related pressures in
2122
is 341 000 pounds
the government has also continued its
income compensation scheme in the first
quarter of 2122.
at the time of writing the report the
amount of compensation for rochester
district was not yet confirmed so it's
not
reported or included in the projected
outrun figures
i'm sorry
i'll
the position will continue to be closely
monitored for the remainder of the year
and will inform the budget setting
process for 2223 onwards
the original capital program for 2122
was 3.6 million pounds
as part of the close down of the 2021
financial year 0.5 million of carry
forward was agreed creating a revised
budget of 4.1 million
the projected outrun on the council's
capital programme as at quarter one is
1.830 million
the major item with slippage against the
revised 2122 budget is the asset
development programme which accounts for
nearly 2 million of the capital budget
this year pending agreement of the first
stop go decision point
the table at appendix 3 summarizes the
projected capital position by service
areas
i suppose the
the just one thing that i'd like to
just re-emphasize chairman
is that
given
the covered pressures given the
complexity of covert pressures on the
council and the council's administration
and it's running
on a budget of 11 million 100 000 pounds
we're just sixty six thousand projected
being adrift at this point as a
percentage that is extremely low and i'm
very pleased with this position at this
point of time
but it's no it's no reason to become
complacent this is going to be a complex
and complicated year from an account
from a financial point of view but um as
always
i'm just the face here the hard work has
been done by naomi and her team and on
each and every opportunity i'll take the
opportunity to to thank her and the team
for the hard work that they do but if
you have got any complicated questions
naomi's they want to answer them thank
you
thank you councillor smith um
naomi lucas did you wish to add anything
before we move into questions
thank you very much indeed and i
certainly endorse those uh comments that
you make councillor smith um
we are fortunate to have a section 151
officer that
manages the finances extremely well and
to all officers for their contribution
to the process but dare i say councillor
smith under your stewardship as a
portfolio holder so
it is team effort but thank you
councillor smith
for what you do right any questions on
the
report that you've heard
i'm not seeing any hands go up so i turn
to
the recommendation has set out in
paragraph 1.1
which says to note the quarter 1 20 21
22 revenue budget and capital position
set out in sections 3 and 4 below
and detailed in appendices one to four
members is that noted
thank you members
moving on to item number eight uh number
nine um it had been thought that uh
a present presentation accompanying item
10
would contain items of confidential
commercial sensitivity and
confidentiality
the chief executive and i are
comfortable that
that is now not the case
and it was our wish in the interest of
total transparency and openness that we
should
do everything we could to avoid going
into an exempt session so as such we
will not be going into an exempt session
and the whole of item 10 will be
within this committee and in the public
domain is that all right members
yes
thank you
moving then to uh item 10
i turn to uh
the deputy leader council mrs cheryl
rowe um and she will i'm sure be ably
accompanied
by dawn tribe assistant director of
transformation and customer
thank you
councillor
[Music]
thank you chairman
can you hear me
um before i start this um
presentation first of all i'd like to to
thank all the staff that have been
involved with this
um it's a big project
so dawn thank you for to you and your
team and to luke
and his team for all he's done thank you
so it was agreed by full council in
february 2020 to create a connect
transformation reserve of 497
847
pounds to fund investor saved projects
identified through the work of the
connect programme
at the july 2021 executive it was agreed
to bring forward the appointment of the
transformation project manager to assist
the key change champions in carrying in
carrying some business and analysis
and identify those investor safe
projects which would fit the connect
invest to save principles
the report you have includes the first
of these investors to save business
cases and seeks approval to draw down
monies from the connect program fund to
implement a customer relationship
management portal
the key change champions have not taken
this challenge lightly this business
case has been through a check challenge
and probe process
and has been endorsed by the leadership
team and the program board
the business case is supported by a
presentation which will be presented by
dawn thank you
the assistant director of transformation
and customer
the presentation will show your officers
talking about how this customer
relationship management portal will not
only change the customers experience but
how how it will save process in time and
in some cases avoid future costs
over to you don thank you
thank you very much councillor
um i am actually a standing because luke
was going to do this presentation
because this is very much his work that
he's put together um but he's
unfortunately able to be with us tonight
because he's um pending the birth of his
his first child so so i i'm standing in
so i hope i do him justice and i'm going
to stand up because um sonia is aiding
as well through the presentation
you've just seen the first um
screen up there that said simpler
smarter services
and this is what this is about
redesigning the customer experience
by 2023 we will have made use of
changing technology to become more
efficient and ensure residents can
contact us more easily and access more
services online that is what we say in
our rdc business plan
it's very easy to say what we will do in
the future however we are what we do not
what we say will do
we need to demonstrate our call to
action
in the past if you had a list of things
that you wanted to do
you would have to
do it by paper sending lots of paper to
wherever you needed to post it to
but now you can transfer money renew
your car insurance and book holiday all
from your phone while eating your
takeaway that you've probably ordered
online
we've gone from innovation to
expectation
with around eight thousand customers
contacting us
through various channels and with each
contact we see last in just under four
minutes to complete tasks that could be
done online we need to make sure that
we're keeping up
phase one of this is already complete
luke has actually reviewed systems with
our officers
had a look at high volume interactions
we have with our customers and noted how
these can be improved
and this presentation
will be will show you through video
your officers
working in their service areas talking
about how this system can improve how
they work and in some cases actual money
future costs to be avoided
some of our digital ambitions are
straightforward
others can be quite complex
regardless of our cust regardless our
customers should need to understand how
shouldn't need to understand how
government works to get the information
they want
they just want us to provide them with
us that the services they need
delivering online service improving the
customer journey journey doesn't have an
end date
it is not a project
it is an
iterative process
our dto which is in the report if you
see that is what we're asking for a
digital technical officer to help us
deliver this system deliver the
following outcomes as part of this
process
luke has worked with the licensing team
speaking to the licensing team about how
they work what they do how we can make
improvements how the system can make
improvements
in order to meet accessibility
regulation central government are
discontinuing the paper-based licensing
forms that they currently use
these forms are critical to us we use
them for processing applications and
taking payments
it is now a licensing team manually
replicate these forms and they're going
to have to do this by march 2022 at the
latest
so they need a replacement solution or
they're going to have to do it
themselves
i think if we just move to the video
showing stephen greener who is the
licensing officer and on your right is
luke mckenzie who is our digital
services manager and i let him speak for
himself to tell you how this is going to
change how they work
the quotes were phenomenal for the class
it was just absolutely ridiculous yes so
basically that says that if we split the
painting over three years
so if we're rolling three years
it'll be
950 pounds for the first year and then
the second year opening nine thousand
fifty pounds and the thirty would be
nine percent
or if you do it all up front it will be
twenty seven thousand pounds that's just
to actually have the system
that doesn't create that doesn't cost
the actual creation of the fulls
if you look at 2.3
they would want
another 4
300 pounds so basically a hundred pounds
per form
to actually maintain the system
and then you've got the license cost
which is two thousand seven hundred and
fifty pounds a year
so the cost just keeps going up and up
and up
and we've got to break it down it's all
broken down there so i can i can then do
the summaries so this is the
conversation
this is how much it's going to cost
every three years you've got to spend
out 27 000
and to be honest i can't sit around
resetting our forms instead of
application forms now doing renewal
thoughts
is just impractical i can't do it not
with whether we've only got two officers
which is myself and one other covering
11 different legislations is just
practical
so that's stephen green are talking
about how much the cost would be
if we didn't implement this system the
customer portal and he would have had to
do all those forms himself and go to
that company and that's the costs and
they are outlined in in the report
we will improve our efficiency through
modernizing service and changing the way
we work to meet residents needs that
again is in our business plan
another example
of where these efficiencies can be had
are in environmental health and luke has
been speaking to the environmental
health officer
and what we want
and what was coming across here is we
want happier more efficient staff who
are equipped with technology they need
to do their job
and we know that
we encourage people to come to the
council if we've got those good the good
technology that they can use to make
them more efficient
offices within the environmental health
team spend a lot of time out in the
field
but have to frequently return to the
office to manually input into data into
back office systems
our current internal technology prevents
us from unlocking the potential for
mobile working
we want our staff to be able to work
easily from wherever they are embracing
what technology can offer
our dto will use the gov service
platform to modernize service delivery
and take the drudgery out of manual
processes by implementing a suite of new
intelligent digital processes that will
capture information around food service
request food premises inspections
pollution and noise
i think if we move on to the video
here this is this is andrew padden
speaking to luke about how he sees this
system will improve how he works and the
customer
a form experience so when the guys are
out in the district doing a food hygiene
inspection they can put the information
directly into the tablet that they've
got with them they can then hit descend
or button whatever and the relevant
information will then get uploaded
straight into uniform
and that for us would be
a quantum leap forward particularly with
the connect project and the supporting
to work remotely
that would then prevent what
remove the need for them to come back to
the office and hand over a hard paper
copy to someone in customer services and
the customer services then wouldn't need
to input it so they would
save up a lot of their time because
they're not having to input stuff and
then i said
we've it cuts out the human error angle
as well there's one less person well i
can't read their hand and what's that
and which does happen so then
information gets input incorrectly uh so
you'll actually improve the accuracy of
what's been the data we're capturing and
save a lot of
complaints but requests we get laid on
their line of work that's wrong oh i
don't know that's what score i wanted
and then we have to go back in and
correct it which takes up a lot of time
so time-wise it would save an awful lot
of officer time it would which i can if
nearly try and work out what that the
hard currency figure on that is
working start is exactly what the
authority is pushing towards it would
allow us to work in that way now this is
something we have looked to try and do
about two years ago
that our system wasn't able to do it
so this would now be and that's why we
did go down that route so this would now
mean we can go down the route that we
wanted to because we have the software
to do it so for us i'm a big fan of this
it would make
our day-to-day working life so much more
efficient which is
what we should be doing
so i think you're getting the idea
that our officers see that this system
is not only going to benefit them but
benefit our customers
we have the same in housing
it takes housing officers 30 minutes to
manually input a housing register
application form
as of may 2021 there were 997
applications on the housing register
our dto will work with the housing team
to build new digital processes that will
automatically sync with their back
office system
this in turn will save over 1 500 hours
of work for the housing team each year
here is michelle flowers housing options
homelessness officer and jeanette
harrell housing options team leader
speaking about how this will speed up
their workflows
[Music]
would cut down the speed
so much
regarding filling those big forms in
because they do take an awful long time
some of them are eight eight pages long
six eighty so if
it and put it back on the system you
know
all of these things that just take up
a lot of time the whole point of
digitalizing it is cutting down time
everybody now has got smartphones
and if it happens they've got access
through libraries etc so it's about
cutting down time
keep going out to collect forms
um
and just trying to make it as digital as
possible really
um to build some forms um you know the
same as the assessment reform to
populate into
the caterer and fill all the information
in then there's quite a huge cost to it
so that's real
life work that they do and undertake
not only will this improve the way that
we interact with our customers
and improve efficiencies
but we're introducing agile working
practices which will involve developing
a new work culture
it's about new ways of working using new
tools new processes new approaches to
management and teamwork that is our rdc
agile working policy
for that to be successful we have to
give everybody the technology
and the right tools to be able to do
this
so it will not only improve externally
but internally some of those processes
at the moment our hr administration is
still paper-based
this is problematic we are setting an
internal procedure for paper-based ways
of working this in turn creates huge
inertia to changing and improving the
way we work that cultural change
our dto will provide our hr team with
the tools and knowledge to challenge
this creating the context in which the
hr team can operate more dynamically and
lead from the front
can you move to the video thank you
constantly improving all of the
processes that we've got to strip out
the paper strip out the old-fashioned
ways of doing things
not only to reduce duplication
and make sure that there aren't any
errors happening and things falling in
gaps that we don't know about but more
than that for us as a team from a
cultural change point of view to by
example so that our internal customers
are coming across processes in their
interactions with us which should be
what they're starting to pick up and
doing their services
so it's that whole leading by example
piece but i think
to get all of our maternity paternity
a workflow process for staffing
requirement course all in this system
would send strong cultural messages to
all of our internal customers that this
is how we now operate this is what you
have to do to engage with us to inspire
other people to do similar and but also
at the moment there's a lot of double
hand lift so i think it will unlock
capacity in hr but unlock capacity for
our managers and it will just mean that
we can use teams for collaboration
rather than checking with each other but
we've all done parts of
still barely paper-based processes so i
think it it plays into all of the
service plan that just been signed off
by andrew hutchings for my service and
how we're going to transform this is
absolutely
integral to supporting us to move from a
transactional team to a transformational
change without doubt
there are other areas internally like
risk management where this can improve
the processes that we do
it can set up reminders timers
clear deadlines tracking and escalation
routes can be pre-built into new
processes to ensure that administration
of data capture
across all service areas is automated
this will help us achieve more by
freeing up skilled resources that are
lost to manual checking and processing
here's our principal performance
business support officer kate o'brien
speaking about the positive impact this
will have on our data capture processes
saving 160 hours of work each and every
year
just in terms of risk there's
20 30 contracts there's 30 services
there's 15 corporate risks that i have
to send this is your last version the
last agreed version
what changes do you want to make
okay do you agree okay accept those
changes leave a copy to show what it was
here's what it is now
and then again six months later
when you add all the services registers
and support for thirty wait some
services are wanting to split
about thirty
at the series
and then we've probably got to be only
doing medium to high risk contracts
we've probably got another 20 or so that
we're looking at towards 100
what would be great as well as if it
could automate so first of january's
popular second game would be generous
7th of january pops up right at times
for review so that's the
whole admin inside of it is taken away
it's just taking care of itself
and then the data is ready to be
analyzed because i'd still want the
freedom to do that because you might
want to cut it 20 different ways and
there's no point of being ill 20 points
i might as well just take the days
i'll do that with it now it's quicker so
if you can take
revenues and benefits
some people only need to access our
services a few times per year have a
short interaction with us and move on
however there are many people who have
complicated busy lives and need lots of
help from us
sometimes for a few months and sometimes
for years
for these users our services can appear
tremendously siloed and difficult to
navigate
a dto will work with revenue and
benefits team to build over 50 true
end-to-end digital processes this will
reduce time being wasted on interpreting
ineligible paper-based applications that
we receive
gathering supporting documentation and
transferring data between departments
for processing
instead information will be captured in
a consistent and accessible way
here is ashley george senior officer
benefits and pam shepard
revenues and benefits manager explaining
why this needs to happen
the last year has only highlighted
the issues you know like the ideal
scenarios we would have been with online
forms and like you say we've been in
that situation where
someone
is smart enough to be able to type in
the answers
on
a
digital version of our home but then we
get it printed off
it's going in it'll just be a massive
win to
it and then we have to retrieve it in
camino so you know we've got customers
emailing in photographs of their form
and we've got to sit and manually import
those emails into camino so
anything we could get direct
customer services this
customer service
are the front line
people call into customer services and
their expectations of what they can do
are becoming more and more digitalized
we use web chat
and they are able to do some
transactions for payments online
but very much their expectations have
changed
people don't want to wait until the
office opens
they want access to their application
and to view that its data's 24 7
on any device by moving services online
our customers can resolve their own
queries at their own convenience
digital forms are key to this channel
shift because they are significantly
better at making government processes
more efficient
you can guide people to fill in digital
forms
errors and inconsistencies can be
challenged at the time of entry you can
understand where people generally drop
off in the process and improve it you
can pre-fill parts of the form for which
you already know some of the answers
our customers should experience seamless
services from us
with the opportunity to give feedback as
this will improve the customer
experience our dto will ensure that at
the end of each digital transaction it
is easy for customers to provide
feedback and comments using the gov
service five-star rating system which is
a bit like the amazon rating system
so we'll get data about how we are
performing
internally our customer services team
will get a 360 degree view of our
customer data in a single place
producing data duplication
they'll be able to easily access the
details of customer interactions
including for example staff notes on a
customer's specific needs such as
contact preferences or a hearing
disability
the system will allow us to be able to
do some real-time reporting
when designing change it's important to
know how we will recognize success you
can't improve what you can't measure
our dto will use real-time reporting to
deep dive into all of our processes and
offer better insights with regard to how
we can operate more efficiently and
better serve our customers
with instant and granular insights into
what is happening within our service
processes we will be able to identify
and resolve bottlenecks and allocate
resources effectively
and this is
a real-time
example there so it doesn't come across
very good on the screen here
so i won't go through what that is but
so quantitative measures 100 of our
online forms made available via the
customer portal
90 of our transactional services are
available digitally
80 percent of received feedback for
digital processes is rated four star
above
seventy percent of our paper uses is
reduced helping us to meet our climate
commitments
that's what we want to achieve and
that's what we can achieve
happy and more productive staff due to
the access to better technology
happy customers as they can access
services when it's convenient for them
better better digital reputation for the
council a groundwork for future digital
growth is established
i don't think the timeline is going to
come up but basically the timeline
is is there and what that shows is
where there are some
hard deadlines like for licensing where
they need to have something in place by
march 2022
that's where we're going to start first
and then we're going to move on to
revenues and benefits because again they
have hard deadlines of when they need to
actually have these forms online
that's the end of the presentation thank
you
thank you chairman dawn thank you very
much for doing that and i know you were
put on the spot at the very last moment
so thank you very much
um i think at this stage members i do
now need to declare an interest because
there's something i want to mention
which relates to my work
so if i could declare an interest as a
company that deals with licensing for
private hire vehicles and private hard
drives
thank you
so um
let's take there's three there's
certainly three departments within that
report that come under my portfolio
licence being one of them
now
as i've just said um i work for a
company that that licenses private hire
vehicles and staff to drive those
vehicles
the papers that those
companies and drivers have to fill in is
phenomenal and so time consuming for our
staff to check
so that will be a plus side for for
licensing
hr that's just forms forms forms um
it's just crazy so so going forward this
can only be positive
customer services so covid has proved
and shown how residents have had to use
online services more frequently
anything to speed this up must be a
positive
so
happy to take any questions and i'm sure
dawn dawn is told thank you chairman
cancel the wood
with regard to my own portfolio of
planning
i'm very very interested to understand
how it's actually going to work within
their say
with the building control especially
where the guys are going to be out on
now i didn't see anything
on this presentation
in regards to that at all
so i'm a little bit disappointed not to
see that on there because that to me
would have been a very important point
of where we've actually got the guys out
on the road and they don't have to come
back
that that would have been something that
i would have valued thank you
council award thank you very much indeed
for those comments and i quite
understand your passion um as the
portfolio holder for planning to
be hungry to want to see that sort of
granular data
so whilst on one side i accept the point
that you're making on the other side
this was a presentation to really talk
about the journey that we're going to
change office systems of which your
planning processes will be very much a
part of in the future so
we look forward at some point to having
a presentation specifically on planning
processes
and how this concept will uh
improve and enhance the productivity of
that area thank you council award thank
you
can i just come back
please gem along thank you
ian councillor i think
you know planning is such a massive
department and
it's going to take a lot longer than a
45 minute presentation to get something
together for that but that will be
looked at
thank you
councillor smith
thank you
we've seen that there are
lots of
opportunities outlined to us in this
project
and as soon as you finish doing the
presentation there are more
opportunities being put forward
obviously as portfolio holder finance i
look at the numbers and the numbers say
this makes sense so why would we not
pursue it and support it thank you
thank you councillor smith
you chairman
this this is great
it's
a shame that it's uh taken so long to
get here because of kovid and everything
else that's gone before i remember one
of the first
chats i had with don when i first took
over the portfolio for it is when we're
going to do something like this he said
she said oh it's in the pipeline she
showed me a list on the wall where it
was on the list
so this is great i can't see why we
would not support this this will make
life so much easier for officers and our
residents
thank you councillor ft councillor webb
thank you chairman i'd just like to echo
those comments and my support for this
project
one thing i just want to draw members
attention to is in
um section 3.3 the in the pipeline for
the future projects as well um one i've
been speaking to matt about already is
the work around the and the assets and
the leases system and an incredibly
exciting piece of work there which i
think makes perfect sense in terms of
starting up our record of assets
and i look forward to that report coming
i believe to exec either october or
november matt is that correct
so through the chairman
thank you
council
award
thank you chairman i didn't particularly
want to sound negative
in regards to to this because i'm not
it's purely the case that i think it's a
fantastic opportunity that it's actually
going to give us
to actually work a lot better a lot
smarter and a lot more economically by
the look of it and of course in relation
to my own department
i believe it's going to enhance
everything we do but not only for our
officers who are out on the road but i
believe for our customers
in regards to planning
and looking at their plans and how they
plan
and i think is the most valuable tool so
i wanted to
echo that on a more positive note rather
than as i started in regards to
questioning the absence of anything or
any mention of planning thank you
chairman
council award thank you very much indeed
for that clarification but you really
didn't need to clarify because anyone
that knows you knows how passionate and
enthusiastic you are
and it was your enthusiasm to ensure
that your own areas under your portfolio
responsibility
were not forgotten it was actually quite
the reverse
and we could sense your your keenness uh
to be a very much integrated part of
this project which of course your area
is
council williams
yeah thank you i love technology bring
it on great excellent thank you
thank you councillor williams
any other
points
what i would like to say um before we
move to the
formal recommendations is that
what we are doing as an authority
is
confronting the challenges that we have
in local government
generally around finance
because
when you see the
impact
of a digital approach
to
systemizing some of these processes but
using
it systems digital systems to aid us you
just realize the huge potential there is
but of course it's about taking people
with us as well as our residents
and they are the key people and we have
also got to bear in mind that not
everyone is going to be able to
deal with digital systems so we do
actually have to straddle the
requirement of some of our residents to
deal with us in the traditional way
that they have been used to talking to
us but also recognizing that the vast
majority
are hungry for us to move over to these
digital systems
but as i sit here
as leader i look at what we've got going
on in this authority at a very strategic
and high level
the asset delivery program which will
modernize all of our buildings across
the district
both in terms of
the leisure
provision that we provide the community
facility as well as the office
and whilst we must rejoice in the
heritage that we have in some of our
buildings we also have to recognize that
we're in a period of change and we have
to respond to that change and ensure
that we work in an efficient way
and we support our community in every
way
our partnership project
with brentwood is indeed also another
way that we are developing efficiency in
the way we work as an authority
the systems that you've talked about
tonight councillor
dawn tribe and others
is so essential
because we will find ourselves in a
world if we don't respond to these uh
challenges
we will be left behind
the great thing i believe actually as an
authority is that we're actually at the
forefront and being visionary in
recognizing the challenges that we face
and we're getting in front of those
challenges
and when we look a little bit wider i
look at a seller the association of
south essex local authorities what we're
not doing is we're not putting a ring
fence around rochford and saying right
the rest of essex can get on with it we
are an integral part of making sure
that the service that we provide
for businesses for residents and for
leisure in our district is an integral
part of the wider essex surrounding us
so i have to say to you i'm very excited
and very proud to be leader of this
authority at this time when actually
we're responding to challenges and
confronting those challenges head on
thank you very much indeed members and
officers
and unless there's any other comments i
will move to the formal recommendations
there are two recommendations set out at
paragraphs 1.1 and 1.2
1.1 to note the pipeline of connect
program invest to save projects being
brought forward following the business
analysis work undertaken by the key
change champions kcc's group
is that noted members
thank you
and to 1.2 to approve the gov service
customer experience platform business
case and drawdown of two hundred and one
thousand pounds two hundred sorry two
hundred and one
two um two hundred one thousand two
hundred pounds we all get tangled up
with our numbers don't we from time to
time from the connect transformation
reserve that's 201
200 pounds from the connect
transformation
reserve do we approve that members
approved
thank you members that concludes the
business for this evening and at uh
8
20 p.m
we close the meeting thank you very much
indeed for your attendance thank you